c'est la première opération du plan
nature dévoilait par la municipalité de
tours la plantation de 1000 arbres et
arbustes sur dix places de la ville les
habitants étaient invités aujourd'hui à
prêter main forte aux agents municipaux
audrey champigny a chaussé les bottes
pour nous elle sous la botte ça creuse
ça creuse
aujourd'hui c'était atelier plantation
aux rives du cher
une trentaine de citoyens tourangeau est
jardinier avait retroussé leurs manches
dans le cadre de l'initiative municipale
pour reverdir la ville
c'est important de planter des arbres
extrêmement important larmes c'est
l'avenir si les générations futures ce
que ce qu'on plante aujourd'hui c'est
pour dans un certain nombre d'années et
deux décennies et les générations
futures
elles aussi ont mis la main à la pâte
et un pue c'est tout ce que je voulais
pas à mendier cerisier chêne liège ou
encore sophora des espèces adaptées au
réchauffement climatique et qui grâce à
leur évapotranspiration rafraîchiront
l'air en période de canicule
alors on a fait une fausse de plantation
de pas loin de 40 cm de profondeur
et puis pas loin de 60 cm de diamètre là
c'est un prunus mal et donc ça va
fleurir au printemps voilà au total ce
sont huit sites qui ont été retenus par
la ville emmanuel denis avait fait
promesses de campagne de planter 30
mille arbres dans différents quartiers
de tours d'ici la fin de son mandat on
plantera pas trempé larves aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est millar mais c'est la
première pierre de notre plan nature qui
va donc se décliner avec cinq axes et
qui permettra à la fin du mandat d'avoir
ces trente mille arbres et arbustes
plantés dans la ville parmi ses axes une
végétalisation des cours de récréation
des vergers et potagers participatif
dans le vieux tours ou bien encore une
mini forêt urbaine au nord de la ville